-I saw "Red State Blue State,"
which is a fantastic show...
where you basically make the
argument that maybe our countr
needs to be two countries.
-Yes. We need to break up.
-Yes.
-At this point, yeah.
We need to break up.
Because it was built
on a flimsy premise
of a country based on debate
dissent, disagreement.
That sounds like
a toxic, negative place
I wouldn't want to live.
-Yeah.
-That's like
I'm starting a bar --
I want to open a bar
for Red Sox and Yankee fans,
and they can debate.
It's going to be a bucket
of blood, like this place.
-You -- It was filmed.
And it's going to be CNN's
first comedy special.
Did you --
At any point in your career,
did you see the trajectory
being toward CNN?
-I did not.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah,
I'm happy it went that way
-I'm very excited
for people to see it.
How have --
Republicans and Democrats --
I know you took it everywhere.
Did they react differently
to the show?
-Well, they only -- No.
-Oh, you only did it here.
-I only did it here.
-Oh, so how was that?
-There's no Republicans
in New York, really.
-Yeah.
-So, you know...
-So you only really got
the one bounce on it.
-Yeah, I got one bounce.
They liked it.
-Yeah, that's good.
What do you --
I know -- You're one of my
favorite people on social media.
How do you feel
like social media is
as a climate
for comedians right now?
-Well, everybody's trying
to be funny on social medi
except comedians.
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They decided to become, you
know, the voice of a nation.
And -- Yeah.
I feel like a lot of peopl
have been weighing in on comedy,
which is really great to hear.
People say, first of all,
punching down.
Let me just start
with "punching down."
Comedy is play-fighting.
It's never been punching.
Second of all,
would have been nice --
either a bigger laugh
or even anything.
[ Laughter ]
But the other point
is the -- Yeah.
Everybody always goes --
People say, you know,
you have to evolve with
the audience as a comedian
And that's true.
That's why I got into comedy
To reinforce mainstream opinion.
So, apparently, people are
missing the point of comedy.
It's not supposed to
march in lockstep with...
-What do you think
about the idea --
I think a lot of people
right now are saying compromise.
We need more compromise.
Do you think that's actually -
Is that a way forward?
-Well, I mean --
You know, we can --
I mean,
compromise is a great idea
except nobody ever compromises
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's --
Nobody's ever compromised
in the history of the world.
This country -- That's why
I said we need to break up
Either that, or it's going t
be a civil war, you know?
And civil war in this country,
you know --
The Battle of Six Flags.
You don't want to see that
-Yeah, I don't want to see that.
[ Applause ]
-Oh.
-How do you feel when you se
this field of Democrats,
who I think we're at,
you know, 20-plus --
-Well, Democrats are play-
It's so funny.
Everybody just
goes right into --
The Democrats are like,
"This guy is not presidential.
We got to get rid of him."
And then he's like,
"Ha! Look at these nerds
calling me unpresidential! Ah!
And they're like,
"Yeah, you tell 'em, Don!"
You know what I mean?"
They need to stand out.
You can't be up there
like, you know,
with this kind of tight-lipped
like, "We have to stop that.
I mean, I understand you wan
to make your policy points
but you got to be a little -
Elizabeth Warren
can't be up there --
She's always looks like
she's in the fourth row
at "Prairie Home Companion."
You know, she should get,
like, Elton John glasses,
or somebody should get like --
You know.
Maybe somebody should get
a neck tattoo.
-A neck tattoo? Yeah.
Do you feel like they should try
to out-Trump Trump?
Do you think that's the wa
you'd do it?
-Yeah, you got to go in ther
and just start taking it
to a new level and go,
"Yeah, right.
He's not going to help.
I'll help you.
You want a 401(k)?
I get you a 501(k).
You let me be president,
you'll have a 601(k)
by the time I'm done.
This guy's nothing.
Look at him. Ah!" You know
-Do you feel like -- Are there
issues the Democratic candidates
are taking on
that you think are strong?
-It's very -- No, they're
very -- It's so funny.
Because Trump, you're like, "Oh,
this is gonna be a cake walk."
Any Democrat can get up there.
You know, first debates.
And you're like,
"Oh, they're just going to
walk through, just go..."
And they're like,
"First order of business.
Felons should vote."
I'm like, "What?"
I'm saying, your first thing
you come out of the gate,
"Felons should vote."
I say, "Oh, you mean people that
did their crime, now they're --"
"No, we mean in jail."
"Oh, I get it.
You mean, like,
low-level misdemeanor?"
"No, rapists and murderers
too."
Okay.
And they're going to wonder,
"Guess what. 2020.
What a fantastic election!
What a great day!
Fantastic day!"
[ Cheers and applause ]